What? Where do I even
Okay, like where do I start? What a time
to be employed. I started a new job
recently for a new startup. I am so
excited. The goal is to be building it
up with them. So, software
engineer, little bit of marketing. You
know how startups can
be.
[Music]
So, looks like someone drugg my face
across the
mat. Okay, so desk is basically brand
spanking new now. So,
let's figure out how we're going to do
this actually. Okay, so here's the
vision.
Desk. Nia off desk. computer on desk,
floating shelves, plants, orchids,
lights,
etc., and just make it so pretty and
dreamy. That's how it is in my head. You
tell me in the comments if it turns out
well. I'm so scared. So, let's see. I'm
going have to be a little handy man for
this one. So, let's see. And you may be
thinking, Nia, why are we spending so
much time on a new desk setup when
software engineering is fried? Well,
Jessica, I think the future of tech is a
lot more nuanced than
that. My photo of flaw is thinking that
Cloroxing the floor is a lot less energy
than breaking out a mop and bucket to
mop it. Okay, I need to see where to put
the floating shelves. So, the desk is
right here. Let me see how big the
computer
is. Okay.
Okay. The computer is this
big, bro. The place I put my floating
shelves is literally I'm not even going
to be able to reach the shelves.
Like, okay, so the computer's this big.
The computer has a stand. So, the
computer is actually going to be like
like at least this tall. So, my floating
shells should be
like there. Hold on. Let me fix the
camera so you can see. Like up here, I
guess. I mean, how
often? How often do I stand at this
desk?
Really? Not often. Let me if I bring it
if I bring it down a little bit. Maybe I
just won't ever stand at the standing
desk.
[Music]
Then literally all three of my task
rabbits canled and so I ended up buying
an electric drill. If I had done this an
hour ago, I would be mounting these
shelves up by now. But hey, we live.
Yeah. No, Task Rabbit. I'm It feels like
an app that was built by an intern a
couple of months ago with the help of
Chat GPT. And I'm saying ChatGBT
specifically because Chat is not that
phenomenal of a coder. If you want a
good coder, go to Claude. Okay, we got
it.
Let's cuz like I'm I'm ready to be done.
I'm so ready to be done. This was
supposed to take not much time and I
haven't even gotten to see my computer
yet. So
we What? So what do we do here?
Exactly,
bro. Ah, I should just read the manual.
Oh, or is it this? Oh.
Aha. Ah,
please. Is it this way? Oh, it's this
way. Okay. Is it on? How does one turn
it on? How does one turn
it
on? Oh, is it
this, bro? Okay. Ah, what is
this? Like, bro, give me some
pictures. Give me some pictures. Give me
a picture book. Is there no on button?
It just turns on. Okay, if you say so.
[Music]
Oh my goodness. The hardest part is
over. There's some shelves over here.
Now I can do the fun part. So, let's put
together like our whole situation. This
better not be something I have
to assemble. It's just a mount or like a
stand for my
computer. Oh, come on. You're lying. Oh,
you're lying to me.
Oh my goodness. Should we open her up?
Okay, let's finally do
it.
Oh my
goodness. How do we turn this on?
Oh, here it is. Oh, I'm about to turn it
on. Okay, I want to film this
though. Oh my
goodness. Oh my goodness. The Hello.
To use English as the main language,
press the return key.
Okay. Thanks, girl. I can use the mouse
now. Ooh, the mouse sensitivity needs to
be adjusted. My
goodness. Okay, while I work on my
computer,
upgrading and getting it to the
migration to work, I guess. I'm trying
not to get stressed about it. I'm going
to install the like back lights I got
for this. Um, I hope there's tape cuz I
don't really have much tape. Maybe I
could like cut up a bunch of little
pieces of the command strips I have.
Maybe I'll do that. So, let's see.
It's these back lights. It's meant for
TVs, but I couldn't find like a smaller
one that would like get here in
time. Ooh, it has a remote
control. Okay, let's
see. Okay.
Uh-huh. Oh, that's pretty simple, right?
We're so close. Like, please. I just
want my dreams to come true. I
beg. Okay. Uh-huh. Do I have to use all
of this? Like, what happens if I What
happens if I cut What happens if I cut a
piece? Does it stop
working?
Bro, this is so
long. I mean, yes, it's for a TV, but
even for a TV, my
gosh. Oh, it has the tape. Oh, that's
fantastic. It
has tape on the back. There we
go. Let's see.
Wait, that looks so cool. You can't even
see
it. Do you see
that? Can I make it
purple? Oh my goodness. Wait, this is
actually
insane. I just want to put this down
here so it's hidden. Oh my.
Wow. Look.
at that.
[Music]